and scott kasmir 37 years old signed a
minor league contract with the giants
this spring and today uk makes his first
big league appearance in five years yeah
who would have thought again you
mentioned 2016
last outing in the big leagues he's been
toiling in the independent leagues he
was a teammate of gabe kapler of evan
longoria back in the tampa days at one
time this guy had an electric left arm
they're hoping to catch lightning in a
bottle today
max muncie hitting 277
eight home runs 23 runs batted in
rifle down the line towards the pole
and a fair ball home run second splash
hit homer for muncie
and max muncie with a home run his ninth
and it's one nothing dodgers
remember once he has had a few splash
hits in san francisco most notable that
one against
the former star of the giants madison
bumgarner as muncie is probably thinking
go get it out of the ocean 26 year old
walker bueller 298 era after seven shout
out innings on monday against arizona
crawford went hitless last night fact he
struck out
three times and walked once a little
comebacker to bueller plenty of time as
he straightens up and lobs it over to
pujols at first base here is
walker mueller voucher passed the
mountain hit very slowly racing in it to
his right it's picked up there by dubai
he makes a spin pivot the quick throw to
first in time he got him and he got it
by a couple of steps so two down and
here is chris taylor the lead off man
who grounded out to longoria now a
swinging strike three
high fastball foul tempt actually into
the glove of buster posey
kasmir's second strikeout that's three
pretty good innings for scott kasmir
buster posey now who grounded into a
double play in the first inning chalkman
away from second the pitch and he got
posey to put it in play slowly rolling
it down to third justin turner
sends it across the infield to albert
pujols
and that is the outside retired inning
over no runs a hit one out and one on
and albert pujol shop ground ball to
third could beat two longoria over the
second one dubon the first two a double
play and the inning is over so one hit
nobody left that's four in the books for
kasmir and he's been excellent he's
throwing a great game so far and he's
got a serious head of hair too he
rivaled brandon crawford right now
giants trailing one nothing
longoria at the plate with one out and
one on chops one to third turner on his
short hop goes to second one muncie to
first in time a double play
around the horn inning ending double
play
that erases the blunt base hit of
brandon belt
so a nice start to the play by turner as
he fielded the short hop and made the
throw right across his body to muncie
and muncie getting it to pujols in the
nick of time double play ends the fourth
on to the fifth
so scott kasmir it looks like his finish
harlan garcia comes on the pitch
kasmir threw 55 pitches that's right
about where he was in his two games in
aaa for the giants
they've got to be thrilled with what
they got from him today
yeah he did a great job i mean
outside of one pitch and that was a
change up to arguably the hottest hitter
in the month of may
max muncie he was he was great i mean no
mistakes
pitch efficient
navigated his way through the lineup
wanna win a one-nothing game here in the
fifth the hitters barnes
austin barnes still looking for his
first home run of the year yanks one in
the air left center field indeed
dickerson back on it he's got it you
spoke it into existence
barnes first home run makes it two
nothing
and barnes he bangs it out of here
it's two-nothing
barnes have been sitting on 200 average
this month
in may
and puts a charge into it i was just
looking down here i just saw a zero and
i'm like man barney doesn't have a home
run yet
[Applause]
this pitch just out over the plate
able to drive that thing into left field
seats
so the dodgers up two nothing and a pair
of solo home runs and over the last
three games all seven runs they've
scored have come off homers muncie's
second two gone tropiano to the plate
with a 2-2
bouncing ball to third for evan longoria
gotta do it for the dodgers in the six
two nothing and the giants offense that
caught fire on their most recent road
trip has just one run on five hits in
the two games of this series will be
duggar leading off the center fielder
came in as part of a double switch last
in it curveball and it's roll to the
right side fair territory right along
the line fielded by pujols he steps on
the bag for the out
stremski who is one for two comes up
pops it up to left field and in the
shadow of the lights
it is matt beatty there to make the
catch bueller and the dodgers have done
a good job with posey in this series
he's over six
punches and bouncer to second there's
muncie and there's a one two three sixth
on 11 pitches two nothing after six in
san francisco luck's the runner at first
matt beatty lined out to first base last
time up haiti rips it to the right field
that's in the corner and around second
and heading for third is lux lux will
come around to score baity around second
he's into third with a run scoring
triple
three nothing dodgers
matt beatty
with his first triple of the season his
19th run batted in
and the dodgers add on in the seventh dj
peters the batter with one out is one
for two he swings and he hits the ball
into left field that'll be down for a
base hit dj peters gets beatty home it's
4-0 los angeles dj peters with his first
major league multi-hit game
first time the giants have had a man in
scoring position today here is longoria
who's grounded a short and grounded into
a double play longoria hits a high fly
ball shallow center out is muncie and
here comes taylor the ball drops in fair
crawford advances to third lux
converging muncie converging taylor
converging and it fell in between them
giants their best opportunity today down
four nothing but first and third with
one out swing and then bloop along the
left field line it is a fair ball base
head
and crawford will come in to score
but he didn't hit that one particularly
well but he certainly placed it well the
giants get their first rbi hit of the
series so the zero was off the
scoreboard for san francisco 4-1 the
score and just like that giants get the
tie and run to the plate in the form of
mauricio dubois
[Applause]
two away in the seventh
four to one la and the pitch
swung on it miss strike three got him
bueller strikes out rough fifth strike
out of the afternoon
he leaves two men and now the dodgers
really have set up shop first and third
and nobody out who holds up floats this
one into left center field he's got
another rbi adding to his totem that's
already third all-time turner's in to
score and the dodgers take the run right
back
look at this wow are you kidding me
you got to be kidding me come to a ball
game get a hall of famer's bat right
here's buster posey oh for three in the
game swings and there's a shot deep down
to the field line and goodbye
that was a laser beam from buster posey
a two-run homer it is
six to three dodgers emily jansen
protecting a 6-3 lead that one's
grounded softly to short candy hop for
lux running throw gets him and the
dodgers have taken the first two from
san francisco
[Applause]